[Music]
I'm an executive protection agent you're
the most wanted hitman in the world it's
my job to keep you alive
how'd that go my bad your bad areas
contain this guy ruined my life
27 times that's how many times you tried
to kill me happy safe from our last what
error without me do you have any idea
how stupid you sound
my husband he's unkillable
how have you stayed alive this can sell
just as rose
I was up here
[Applause]
[Music]
okay hon three one man killed over 150
people
250 jeez
[Music]
come with us okay whoever said please
wait are we always yelling
[Music]
you're living the dreams DP yeah
devil-may-care auditor strong highs
beautiful girlfriend
sorry I'm late I was rounding up all the
gluten in the world and launching in
space where it can't not hurt us ever
again
kiss me like you missed me read what in
the ass
my name's cable I'm here for the kid
what the kid movie guy
kids give us a chance to be better than
we used to be you need you lot smarter
than I look
Menten cable kill this kid I can't do
this alone
we're gonna form a super duper group
that's what we're gonna be
forward-thinking gender neutral you will
be known as x-force a little derivative
you're absolutely right now cue the
music
tell me they got that in slow motion
you're the right thing is messy you want
to fight for what's right dirty Matt is
why the man bun is just a millennial
mullet oh god I wish I finished college
it lives up to the hype
plus plus they probably won't even make
it three yeah why would they stop it -
you killed it you cuttin it close
oh good morning miss date I need you
around this weekend you have a problem
with that
no I just my grandmother's 90th birthday
so I think who's gonna go home and it's
fine I'll cancel it so your family yes I
tell you to quit every single day
Margaret Tate's office this isn't about
my second raise is it how could your
visa application is denied you're being
deported deported it's not like I'm an
immigrant or something I'm from Canada
if you deported you can't work for an
American company if there was any way at
all that we could make this thing work
bargain eruption I understand the
predicament but there is something that
you should know we are worried getting
married who is getting your night you
and I are getting married yes we are
getting married yes can't if I don't
can't find love like ours so uh are we
good make it all legal we'll put this
- I'm not gonna marry if you don't
you'll be on the street all alone
looking for a job have the two of you
told your parents about your secret love
we're going through their places we can
no more cell
Alaska Alaska where is Landers room
hello sleep in here with you we'd love
to snuggle don't we for the huge
snuper's sorry what is it how can you be
around someone I made your life so
miserable sweetie
some proposals change you why don't you
get married here tomorrow let's see a
kiss why are you still a mess Oh for
better or worse
[Music]
real kiss
[Music]
[Applause]
Sandra Bullock Ryan Reynolds are you
proposal maybe a tad loose in certain
areas I'm a bit shifty to begin with
it's like an easter egg
[Music]
[Music]
Mondays am i right Joe don't have a good
day have a great day hey but let me
think that there's got to be more more
than what stuff we do it day after day
being shot at run over taken hostage
today's gonna be different
hi this isn't you you don't do this man
he's just resting
[Applause]
[Music]
is this what recreational drugs feel
like guy this world it's a video game
and it's full of bad guys I'm a rule
breaker I'm a rattlesnake guy we need
you to be good good guy
giddyup
is that a Glock in your pocket know what
it's two clocks
[Music]
I'm not gonna be the good guy I'm gonna
be the great guy okay Wow enjoy your
lifetime supply of virginity you go hey
guys it's a girl
congratulations any idea who the father
is
shut up what's 30 times all right let's
go three two one
[Music]
this is dr. David Jordan our mission is
to intercept a research pond from Mars
sixteen steps to fix the shower I'm an
astronaut not a gym teacher this is the
first capsule ever to come back from the
clinic we have visual confirmation I
said this could be a major scientific
breakthrough of life beyond the rim
oxygen no carbon dioxide it's beautiful
and finally a daddy
it's gonna be a big custody battle over
this one no we're gonna keep it up here
we're gonna study where it's safe
you can't fastest growing every single
single is a muscle cell I don't have
cell or muscle membrane how smart is
this
[Music]
these creatures wiped out Mars
millions of years ago if we let it get
to earth all human life let's kill the
thing good night moon good night moon
good night cow jumping over the moon
good night light the red balloon
what is the primal instinct of any
life-form to survivor good night stars
we've lost all communication good hair
just look at the atmosphere in 39
minutes funny I'm changing but it could
mr. this everywhere
[Music]
welcome to rhyming city a celebration of
the harmony between humans and pokémon
Tim your dad was a legend in this
precinct if you were anything like your
tanner I remember you wanted to be a
pokémon trainer anyway yeah yeah that
didn't really work out
[Music]
come in there whoever you are and not to
use this
geez here we go I know you can't
understand me but put down the stapler
or I will electrocute you did you just
talk whoa did you just understand me oh
my god you can understand me I've been
so lonely they try to talk to me all the
time all they hear is pika pika you can
hear him right guys adorable you're
adorable they can't understand me
kitchen no one else here I don't need a
Pokemon period and what about a
world-class detective because if you
want to find your pops
I'm your best bet we're gonna do this
you and me
[Music]
it brought us together and that magic is
called hope
[Music]
listen up we got ways to make you talk
or mine
yeah so tell us what we want to know
pipe yes okay I can shoving pushing my
problem is that I push people away and
then hate them for leaving he's saying
you can shove it what I can shove it
okay that's it no we're switching roles
I'm bad cop you're good cop
in my head I saw that differently
[Music]
great life has got up in the universe
worlds are not elective lanterns we face
an unprecedented danger an enemy
powerful enough to destroy entire
civilizations to fight this enemy the
ring chose a human
I need to tell you your duty
[Music]
your name Hal Jordan the ring chose you
take a check
speedy on speed field if everybody knows
the oath I pledge allegiance to a
lantern that I got from a dying purple
alien so this is the chosen human the
Renton's thought into reality its limits
are only what you can imagine the sword
Oh human
remember your enemy is not gonna play
there I think it is and they lead a life
that were under the first that mankind
has ever encountered
so we're gonna catch you well again I
have never
better in my life they said they
would've chosen me you didn't see
something that I don't see it I said
that the ability to overcome fear
stay here no problem if you die innocent
lives will be lost your world will be
annihilated
[Music]
help me save my planet fight fight it
with me
[Music]
well escape my sight those who worship
evils might beware my god
like
[Music]
[Music]